[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing something that exists in both
the harry potter world
and our own world something that most of
us want
something that drives economy and
something that certainly pushes
some to madness i am of course talking
about
money gold shekels galleons
sickles canuts pounds dollars you name
it
the wizarding world is certainly
different than our own muggle world in a
lot of ways
but one way that they're almost
completely the same surrounds
the structure of their economy economies
are
systems of making and trading things of
value divided into goods
physical things and services things done
by people
it assumes there is medium of exchange
which in the modern world is a system of
finance
so whether you're muggle or magical in
order to obtain goods or services
medium of exchange is required and this
is where money comes in
depending on where you live everyone
uses different forms of currency
and in the wizarding world this currency
is comprised of galleons
sickles and canuts in depreciating order
galleons being the largest are worth
about 17 sickles
or 493 cannots but that's enough about
types of money
that's not the focus of this video the
main focus is
who is the richest that's right just
like our own world there is an uneven
distribution of money in the wizarding
world
there are rich families poor families
and some people in between
the distribution of this wealth and its
inequality
is called the wealth gap which is in
essence
an unequal distribution of assets using
the united states as an example
a 2013 study showed that the top 10
percent of families
accounted for 76 percent of the nation's
entire wealth
and that the bottom 50 percent of
families accounted for just
one percent of the nation's total wealth
this is a horrifying statistic
but something tells me that there's
something similar going on
in the harry potter universe based on
what we see in the series
there seem to be an awful lot of vaults
full of gold as well as an awful lot of
wizards
doing everything they can just to get
some of the scraps
i think that a lot of this has to do
with old money
that is money that has been passed down
for generations
in certain wizarding families to add to
all of this
there seems to be an awful lot of
emphasis placed on money and status
in the series it's emphasized time and
time again
that the weasleys are poor think my name
is funny do you
well no need to ask yours red hair and a
hand me down robe
you must be a weasely that lot won't
come cheap said george
the quick look at his parents lockhart's
books are really expensive
well we'll manage said mrs weasley but
she looked worried
let's see red hair vacant expressions
tatty secondhand book you must be the
weasleys
inversely harry's immense wealth seems
to be constantly mentioned
inside were mounds of gold coins columns
of silver
heaps of little bronze canuts harry said
nothing
he felt a bit awkward stored in an
underground vault at gringotts in london
was a small fortune that his parents had
left him
harry felt even worse when they reached
his vault he tried to block the contents
from view
as he hastily shoved handfuls of coins
into a leather bag
but just as the weasleys certainly
aren't the poorest harry certainly isn't
the richest
even despite the constant mentions of
his innumerable wealth
so who is the richest is it perhaps the
malfoys
they always seem to be praised as
wealthy individuals right
as it turns out the generational wealth
that the malfoys possess
started with the wizard named armand
malfoy
who arrived in britain with william the
conqueror having rendered unknown
shady and almost certainly magical
services to king william the first
malfoy was given a prime piece of land
in wiltshire
seized from local landowners upon which
his descendants have lived
for 10 consecutive centuries having land
ownership so early on in history
is certainly an advantageous start
however as it turns out
part of the malfoy wealth came from
muggles the result is that they are one
of the richest wizarding families in
britain
and it has been rumored for many years
though never proven
that over the centuries the family has
dabbled successfully
in muggle currency and assets over
hundreds of years they have managed to
add to their lands in wiltshire
by annexing those of neighbouring
mughals and the favor they carried with
royalty
added muggle treasures and works of art
to an ever-expanding collection
historically the malfoys drew a sharp
distinction between poor muggles
and those with wealth and authority
until the imposition of the statute of
secrecy in 1692
the malfoy family was active within
highborne at muggle circles
and it is said that their fervent
opposition to the imposition of the
statute
was due in part to the fact that they
would have to withdraw from this
enjoyable sphere
of social life so they were wealthy in
both worlds
to add to this in the deathly hallows
the death eaters and voldemort
hold their meeting at the malfoy manor
and it certainly doesn't sound like a
building to scoff at
when yaxley and snape approach the manor
yaxley snarls
and notes that there are peacocks on the
grounds he murmurs with an edge of
jealousy that lucius malfoy always
did well their grandest state expensive
pets roaming the property
and dimensions of wealth throughout the
books and films really seem to support
the argument that they're the wealthiest
however they're not in fact i can think
of two families richer than them
right now starting with the lestranges
the lestrange vault gringotts was one of
the most well protected
and not just because of the horcrux held
inside but also
because of the immense stacks of gold
inside the door of the vault melted away
to reveal a cave-like opening
crammed from floor to ceiling with
golden coins and goblets
silver armor the skins of strange
creatures some with long spines
others with drooping wings potions in
jeweled flasks
and a skull still wearing a crown okay
so why were the strangers so wealthy
well the main reason for this is that
the strange family
had old money but it's not just their
old money that made them so rich
you see at one point the blacks another
family with old money
married into the lestranges and then the
two worlds of money collided
bellatrix lestrange who we know was a
pure blood witch that hailed from the
black family
and later married into the pureblood
lestrange family
both the black family and lestrange
families were wealthy in their own right
both stemming from the sacred 28 a
directory of truly pureblood families
that still existed within the wizarding
world bellatrix and her husband rodolfos
ended up with a large portion of the
money from both family trees
and the combination of these fortunes
made them immensely wealthy
even richer than the malfoy's most
people think that
these two are the wealthiest but i think
i know of someone even wealthier
the true wealthiest ever heard of the
immortal philosopher
enter nicola flamel i know what you're
thinking
wasn't he just some humble old fart that
obsessed over alchemy
well it was a bit more than that first
of all nicola flamel
exists in both our own world and the
harry potter world
flamel was a french scribe but born in
the 1300s in the city of pontois
he lived in paris for the majority of
his life and spent much time there over
the course of the 14th and 15th century
flamel was such an influential figure in
parisian history that there is even a
road named after him called rue nicola
flamel on a day-to-day basis flamel
worked as a scribe and manuscript
seller and ran two shops offering these
services in paris
flamel achieved a great deal of success
in his career
and as a result became quite wealthy in
the year 1368 flamel would go on to
marry his wife
perranelle a generous benefactress who
had a great deal of money from her
former two marriages
the joining of the two meant that they
would become immensely wealthy
but what's interesting is that their
wealth at this time was just at the tip
of the iceberg
flamel ended up living to somewhere
between 666
and 670 years old and that's thanks to a
little object
called the philosopher's stone ever
heard of it
flamel an alchemical master created the
stone
earlier on in his life an object of
exceptional wonder
and magical properties one of the unique
properties of the philosopher's stone
was that it allowed whoever possessed it
to create one of the most powerful
potions in existence
an elixir of life flamel capitalized on
this property of the stone
and this is why he was able to live for
such a long time
however that wasn't the only property of
the stone
ever heard of king midas and the midas
touch well
let me refresh you king midas was a
figure from greek mythology
that had the ability to turn anything to
gold simply by touching it
flamel's stone though limited when
compared with the powers of king midas
held similar properties and had the
capacity to turn
any metal into pure gold a stone that
can turn
any metal into pure gold sounds like we
may have a new contender
for richest wizard flamel of course
eventually dies
but in the 666 or 670 odd years that he
existed on the planet
i'm sure he had one or two opportunities
to turn objects into gold
in fact i'm willing to bet that he
capitalized on it
add that to the already immense wealth
that he and perenelle held
and well we've got a winner what do you
guys think did you expect the positively
unassuming nikola flamel to be the
richest wizard
who did you think it was leave your
comments down below
until next time as much money and life
as you could want
the two things most human beings would
choose above all the trouble is
humans do have a knack of choosing
precisely those things
that are worst for them